Before launching into a pension today.
I thought I would just take a few moments
to look back over the books that we've
read and talk about the
visions of language that
they have offered us and also
just to reflect for a
moment on the relationship.
Imagine between those visions of
language and what is happening outside of
fiction in in what we
might call the real world.
We started this course talking about black
boy and the way that a whole world of
pressure,
political pressure,
racial tension pushed on the borders of
that work and actually changed it's very
material form.
After that I began a series of readings
of novels that emphasized more what you
might call the history of literature,
the history of literature,
forms and ambitions and so beginning that
series we had O'Connor embodying a new
critical craft of fiction that comes
out of modernism imagining nevertheless
that that craft is reflective of a
transcendental order in the world or
religious order.
Okay.
When we moved on to Nebach off,
we had an author trying
to imagine a work of art,
so autonomous from the world that it
could be something like an autonomous form
of life.
That of course I argued in those lectures,
opened it up for the threat of mortality.
If you imagine your artwork
is living at can also die.
It's a kind of haunted Agnus
that surrounds Nepal, coughs,
vision of aesthetic bliss.
Um,
as one's response to
that autonomous artwork,
Kira whack represents a
whole group of writers.
The beats who reject the formalism
embodied by both O'Connor and Novaka off.
Okay.
They reject that formalism
as an impediment to languages
access to the real and
to our access to the
real through language.
They dream of an unmediated relationship
between experience and the word.
They don't think so much of
language as a mediating force,
as an expressive force.
Yeah.
I argued in my lecture second lecture on,
on the road that in the end that dream
looks quite deflated when Dean can't even
speak in a coherent sentence and
he has to be rejected by sal.
As Sal drives off to the jazz concert.
At Carnegie Hall.
Nevertheless,
that dream is spiritualized.
It's a way of becoming, not
just, uh, close to the real,
but also part of some mystical unity.
That thread of the mystical quality of
language at its extreme of literary power
is what I drew out of Franny and Zooey.
So Salinger two has the dream that
the artifice of literature of Literary
language,
the performance of language and the
style of his novels can somehow be the
essence of the human soul.
That it can somehow,
uh,
communicate the truth of the
universe just through its form,
its human distinctive form.
It's a way of thinking about form
that has more to do with, uh,
individuality than it
does with convention.
Remember that way that Franny can identify
the Tambour of her brother's voice,
very specifically,
it's like no other.
Okay,
so sound,
you're imagines that the literary art
imitates that kind of voice and in that
way it is a sacred practice,
a sacred art.
Okay.
Barth rejects the idea that language
is an unmediated form of access to the
real, absolutely impossible for
Barth to countenance that idea.
He sees life as continually,
always already mediated by language.
Now I should say as as,
um,
someone from the class who came up to
me after lecture asked me about this,
that Barthes understanding of language
as preceding human understanding
proceeding any sense of ourselves in a
sense always slipping out of our control
is very much in concert with what was
going on at very high level language
theory at that time.
So the work of Jacques Lacan in
France in the 1950s and sixties,
and of Jacques Derrida who
brought deconstruction to
the United States actually
to Johns Hopkins,
first of all in the 1960s
where Barth was teaching,
he presented that work
in a famous lecture, um,
in the late sixties.
This is all part of a way of thinking
about language that became very powerful
through the next decade and a half.
And we're going to see it
some too next week. Uh,
when we read Morrison
and Maxine Hong Kingston.
So this is part of a larger
intellectual trajectory.
Barth is not alone in thinking
these things about language.
I argued that Barth tried to counter that
sense of helplessness at the hands of
language by imagining that the human
effort at connecting with another person
through the mechanisms of love and
desire always renewed the possibility for
language to do new kinds
of work in the world.
So if language seems exhausted
because it's always preceding you,
everything has always already been said,
there's no new plot to be had.
The world is full of stock phrases.
How do you use them to embody and
experience that seems fresh to you.
How do those stock phrases alienate you
from the very experience you hope that
they can describe?
He thinks that following out desire can
renew language and mentally ad I think
is his attempt at doing that.
So now we arrive at pension and I want
to suggest that Barth was still dreaming
of a pretty autonomous
version of the literary art,
even though in his 1987 preface
to loft lost in the fun house.
I don't know if any of
you read it. Um, he,
he says about these stories which
were published throughout the 60s.
The high sixties, like the roaring
twenties was a time of more than unusual,
more than usual ferment
in American social,
political and artistic life are unpopular.
War in Vietnam,
political assassinations, race riots,
the hippy, counterculture, pop art,
mass poetry,
reading street theater,
vigorous avant garde ism in all the arts
together with dire predictions not only
of the depth of,
of the novel,
but of the more abundant t of the print
medium in the electronic global village.
Those flavored the air we breathe.
Then along with occasional tear
gas and other contaminants,
one may sniff traces of
that air in the funhouse.
I myself found it more
invigorating than disturbing me.
The reader find these stories.
Likewise,
it's a very interesting little
comparison he makes at the end.
He takes that whole foment of
1960s politics and counterculture.
And essentially he says,
I found that invigorating as I hope you
will find these stories invigorating as
if the stories in this very
almost seemingly hermetically
sealed literary world
that he offers us are somehow meant to
have the effects of a whole decade of
foment social foment.
Okay.
If Barth only gestures towards that world,
the politics of that decade
pension actually lets us,
uh,
see it.
And if you look on page 83,
uh,
this is just one of many,
many examples,
but I choose this one just
because it's so obvious.
Yeah.
Add a pie is going to Berkeley
looking for Emery boards
and she comes a on a summer,
weekday in the midafternoon.
No time for any campus at a new have
to be jumping yet. This one was,
she came down slope from Wheeler Hall
through Sather Gate into the plaza,
teaming with Corduroy Denim, bare
legs, blonde hair, horn rims,
bicycle spokes in the sun,
bookbags swing card tables,
long paper petitions dangling to
earth posters for undecipherable,
f. F. S. Ms y a. N. S. Y v.
D sees suds in the fountain,
students nose to nose and dialogue.
She moved through it, carrying
her fat book attracted, unsure,
a stranger wanting to feel relevant,
but knowing how much of a search among
alternative universes it would take.
Four, she had undergone her own
educating at a time of nerves,
blandness and retreat not only
among her fellow students,
but also most of the visible
structure around and ahead of them.
That whole world of government and,
and social life at a Pi is an a different
generation of a different generation,
but we can see the social foment just
in that little snapshot of the Berkeley
campus. Those, I don't
know all of the acronyms.
I don't know what the fsms are,
but the why ETFs are the
young Americans for freedom.
The vcs are the Vietnam Day committees.
Um,
the Vietnam Day Committee
organized a 24 hour teach in,
in 1965 against the Vietnam war.
Hmm.
There's a little anecdote from that teach
him that I want to share with you that
I think embodies some of
the tensions in this knob.
Cool.
They invited Ken Keasy to come and
speak at the convention at the teaching.
Now, Ken Keasy, uh,
some of you probably know was
a sort of performer, writer,
not really an activist.
Um,
he was a purveyor of street theater and
most famously the advocate of LSD and he
and his merry pranksters would a ride
around the country doing street theater
advert advocating the use
of LSD and marijuana. Um,
who in 1964 do you think drove their bus,
which was called further.
Who Do you think drove their boss?
Neal Cassady.
Neal Cassady drove their bus when they
came to the Vietnam Day at the Berkeley
campus. Keasy addressed the
assembled people saying,
turn your back on the war.
Look at the war.
Turn your back on the war and say,
fuck it.
Yeah.
This is a group of people
he was addressing who were
intent on doing something
to stop the war.
And this was keasy his response.
That moment for me embodies these,
this tension right at
the senator of the 1960s,
attention between countercultural
self development and an ethos of play
drop out, uh, tune in.
I can't remember. Keys, these
little hole, a little motto. Um,
essentially leave the
institutional life of America.
That means schools, government, politics,
all those traditional sources
of water and create disorder.
And do that as a way of finding
what's true about yourself.
Do it in the company of others.
It had this communal aspect for sure.
On the other side,
you have a growing political
movement among young people.
And of course it's legendary.
By 1964,
the civil rights movement had
accomplished amazing things.
So as a result of the freedom rides,
they had integrated interstate
transportation at great
cost to the volunteers
who wrote those buses. They were
beaten. Uh, some were killed,
civil rights workers were
murdered in various states. Um,
it had come to a kind of crescendo with
voter registration drives and the voting
right act rights act of 1964.
At the same time,
uh, Lyndon B Johnson was
ratcheting up of the Vietnam War.
So the Gulf of Tonkin resolution was
passed in 1964 which authorized bombing
raids on Cambodia.
This was a new turn in the war
and it promised to escalate it.
And this really galvanized,
especially student resistance.
So this was a time of major political
stakes and young people at universities,
primarily at universities, but also
people out doing the march on Washington,
uh, in the south, in small towns,
we're really changing the face of
America and its role in the world.
So can keasy on the one hand is looking
for that internally directed playful
response to the oppressive
order of the world.
And then there's this very
political response pension
let's us see both and he's
parodying both kinds of
response in this novel.
So in that sense,
the novel is very much of its time.
Now I want to, uh, pause for a
moment there and asks you a question.
I want you to think about what kind of
protagonist pension sends out into this
world.
What do you think of [inaudible]?
How does she strike you as a character?
How would you describe her?
Yeah,
that's true.
Desperate. Okay. How else?
Yeah, powerless. Powerless.
[inaudible]. Confused. Confused.
What else?
Those are all pretty, um,
pretty negative adjectives.
Does she bring any resources?
Yes.
She's attractive. Yes, she is. What else?
What other resources does she bring?
Yeah, she's curious. She's curious.
Yeah. What else? Anything else
determined [inaudible]
when this book first came out,
critics called her a lightweight.
Was that a word that ever occurred to you?
Did anyone think this is
just a fluff character?
Okay.
I would suggest to you that the difference
in your response and the critics is a
difference. The difference that
feminism in the 70s made, um,
in the 1960s to have a protagonist
go into the world and discover this
incredibly complex set of patterns.
Uh,
and to have that protagonists to be a
housewife was very much playing against
type.
So pinch and took a certain kind of risk
by choosing to make his protagonist to
housewife.
So the question is why did he do that?
I want to suggest to you
that he did that because
a woman is to occupy certain conventional
roles at this moment and we see her in
one at the very beginning of the novel.
She is,
has just come back from a Tupperware party
where the waitress or the hostess put
too much cure in the punch.
So she's a little drunk.
So you get this image of her as this
stereotypical 50s housewife going to
Tupperware parties and then she
makes salad. She does the shopping,
she picks her herbs from the garden,
she makes Lasagna,
she mixes drinks so that they'll
be ready when mucho comes home,
when her husband comes home.
Very typical.
So this is the moment in
which she discovers that
she's been chosen or named as
the executor tricks of Pierce's will.
Okay.
It's that conventionality that then
allows her to occupy multiple roles.
And let me just, um, detail some of those.
You see it almost in language of a side.
Um,
this is when she first meets Gangas Cohen.
Yes.
Now the names in here,
we have to think about them at some point.
Um,
one thing you can say about
them is that they are funny.
A second thing you can say about them
is that they seem redolent of meaning.
I can't tell you how many scholars have
come up with different readings of what
Ed oppose name means.
That's just ed a.
And then there were so many hundreds of
others. Um, they are redolent of meaning.
What are we to do with that fact?
That's a question for you. Three,
they declare that language
is always mediated,
always mediating that your experience
of people is never clear of some set of
meanings that someone
else has assigned to it.
Your encounter with the
world is always mediated.
So these names drag associations with
them and one question you want to ask is
what to do with those,
but I'm going to set that question
aside for a moment and note that at at
meeting Gangas at a puff
felt at once motherly.
Yeah.
Now this may seem like a small aside,
but if we look also on 73
when she meets Mr Thought,
she says on the, on the very top topic
he's telling at OPA her dream, his dream,
and she sees in it clues to
the third and taxes mystery,
Oedipus sensitized,
thinking of the bronze marker smiled at
him as granddaughter Lee as she knew how
and asked did he ever have to fight
off desperadoes. And then of course,
she gets a major clue for figuring out
what the whole story is behind the truth
stereo and the post
torn granddaughter Lee.
It's a role she can occupy,
uh, with great ease.
A last example on one 22
this is when she's going
to meet, uh, Emery boards
at upper showered,
put on a sweater skirt and sneakers,
wrapped her hair in a student like twist,
went easy on the makeup.
These are her resources,
makeup,
clothes,
hair with them.
She can occupy all these different roles.
And in doing so, she has access
to certain kinds of knowledge.
Her roles are s fluid in some ways,
as Pierce's were.
Remember that when Pierce calls her,
he's always impersonating someone.
So he was speaking with his
Lamant Cranston voice the
last time that she spoke
to him.
The difference between the way at Hipaa
occupies these various roles and pierce
did it,
is that adipose roles have a kind of
traction in the world with other people
that,
that pierces voices or even Dr Hilarious.
His voices simply don't have
these male versions of it are all.
So apparently performances
that they can't, uh,
they can't get much out of them
except to a noise at a pub.
But at OPA jumps right into
these conventional roles.
And in that act comes to know more
about the world in a way that these men
cannot
add a Pi is even from,
from the time she was a child,
a reader.
And we find that out on page 14
when she has her religious instant.
And I hope you remembered
that scene of um,
sal looking down on Salt Lake City,
the birthplace of,
of Dean from on the road.
Very similar structure.
He looks down and he sees the
little city laid out, uh, below him.
So this is at OPA.
In one of the first instances
of her becoming a reader,
she looked down a slope needing
to squint for the sunlight.
This is when she first sees
San Nurses sent, I'm sorry,
San Narcisso onto a vast sprawl of
houses which had grown up together like a
well tended crop from
the dull brown earth.
And she thought of the time she'd opened
a transistor radio to replace a battery
and seeing her first printed circuit.
The ordered swirl of houses and streets
from this high angle sprang at her.
Now with the same unexpected astonishing
clarity as the circuit card had,
though she knew even less about radios
than about southern Californians.
There were two both outward patterns,
a hieroglyphic sense of concealed
meaning of an intent to communicate.
There'd seemed no limit to what the
printed circuit could have told her if she
had tried to find out.
So in her first minute of San Narcisso,
a revelation also trembled,
just passed the threshold
of her understanding.
Smog hung all round the horizon.
The Sun on the bright beige
countryside was painful.
She and the Chevy seemed park at the
center of an odd religious instant,
as if on some other
frequency or out of the,
I have some world wind rotating
too slow for her heated skin,
even to feel the centrifical
coolness of words were being spoken.
She suspected that much.
She thought of Mucho her husband
trying to believe in his job.
Was it something like this?
He felt looking through the soundproof
glass at one of his colleagues with a
headset clamped on and queuing the next
record with movements stylized as the
handling of Chrism Sensor
Chalice might be for a holy man,
yet really tuned in to the voice voices,
the music.
It's messaged surrounded by digging it
as were all the faithful at went out to,
did Mucho stand outside
studio a looking in,
knowing that even if he could hear it,
he couldn't believe in it.
She gave up presently as if a cloud had
approached the son or the smog thickened
and so broken the religious instant,
whatever it might have been.
Yeah.
Here the cloud becomes the obscuring of
this sense of intent to communicate or a
sense of meanings pattern,
but it still retains as it
did in Flannery O'Connor.
That spiritual sense that the
divine is always shrouded round.
Bye.
Some cloud of unknowing
here.
We see her with the desire to know and
the difference between her as a child and
her in this moment is that she had not
bothered to find out if she had tried to
find out about the radio circuit,
she would've learned something.
She did not try this time she will try.
So she's a reader who notices patterns
even from a young age and at this moment
she has called upon and she rises to the
occasion to figure out what the pattern
will mean.
And of course she progresses through
a kind of education as a reader.
She goes from being a reader
who can listen. For example,
to the ambiguity's in the war finger play.
She can hear when the ambiguity creeps
in between the words and that tells her
that she needs to find something out.
That's what causes her to have
the curiosity to go backstage.
She becomes a critic.
She moves from interpretation
to actually finding the history and the
intertextuality and the variations of
these additions of the play.
She learns history of the u s and
of Europe about the mail systems.
She learns the history of
[inaudible] enterprises.
So she becomes a scholar in a
certain way in amateur scholar.
She's not just a reader. She is
someone who actually performs research.
Where does all this get
her? Well, I think, uh,
what we're led to believe is precisely
nowhere in terms of revelation.
Does a revelation ever happen?
Of course,
the book ends with her waiting for the
anonymous bitter to reveal himself.
Whether that would ever happen if
pension had decided to let us in on the
secret,
I don't know.
Pension instead chooses to end
the novel before that moment.
Yeah,
and so we're left with a
kind of emptiness. We're left
with the multiple options
that
she laments.
If you look on one 46 one 47,
she rehearses all the possibilities
of meaning
and her conclusion.
Finally.
Okay,
is this San Narcisso,
was the name an incident among our
climatic records of dreams and what dreams
became among our accumulated daylight,
a moment's squall line or tornadoes
touchdown among the higher,
more continental solemnities storm
systems of group suffering and need
prevailing winds of affluence.
There was the true continuity.
San Narcisso had no boundaries,
no one knew yet how to draw them.
She had dedicated herself weeks ago to
making sense of what in virality had left
behind.
Never suspecting that
the legacy was America
and then I'm going to
skip down a little bit
so she could never again call back any
image of the dead man to dress up, pose,
talk to and make answer.
Neither would she lose a new
compassion for the CULDESAC.
He tried to find a way out of for
the enigma has efforts had created.
What we don't get here is
a sense of whether there
really is an alternate secret
postal system that serves a sort
of underground of private networks.
We don't ever get a sense of whether
these stamps and the signs that she sees
everywhere in San Francisco when she
travels through the city in the night,
whether these things
are a coherent meaning
or
whether they are her fabrication,
we don't really know and she never really
can say all she has is the sense that
there is this pattern.
Now there are two things that
she's left with in the passage.
I just read that sense of sooner so
being all of America and moreover of it
being constituted of storm systems of
group suffering and need to remember all
the little sub communities that she
interacts with have some sort of pain or a
loss associated with them.
The inner Morati anonymous for example,
people who don't want to love,
it's all comedy,
but then there is a heart,
a colonel,
and if we look on page one oh one one oh
two we can begin to see what that heart
or kernel is
that recuperates what I
would call the sentimental.
So this is when she's in San
Francisco looking around the city.
She's come,
they're hoping to escape the network of
symbols that she has seen all those post
warrens and instead she's immersed
with a new network of them.
Okay.
We're told just before
the morning rush hour,
she got out of a Jitney who's ancient
driver ended the day in the red ended each
day in the red downtown on Howard Street,
began to walk toward the Embarcadero.
She knew.
She looked terrible knuckles black with
eyeliner and Mascara from where she'd
rubbed mouth tasting of old booze and
coffee through an open doorway on the
steer leading up into the disinfectant
smelling twilight of a rooming house.
She saw an old man huddled,
shaking with grief.
She couldn't hear both hands smoke white
covered his face on the back of the
left hand. She made out the
post torn, tattooed and old ink.
Now beginning to blur
and spread fascinated.
She came into the shadows and ascended
creaking steps hesitating on each one.
When she was three steps from him,
the hands flew apart in his wrecked face
and the terror of eyes gloried in burst.
Veins stopped her. Can I
help? She was shaking tired.
My wife's in Fresno. He said he
wore an old double breasted suit.
Fred Gray shirt wide tie. No hat. I
left her so long ago. I don't remember.
This is for her.
He gave out a letter that looked like she
had been carrying around for years and
he tells her to drop it in the,
in the w a s t e lady.
Um, can waste. We're not
allowed to see waste. Remember?
Uh,
and then she is gripped with,
as she says,
uh,
overcome all at once by a need to touch
him as if she could not believe in him
or would not remember him.
And she reflects just above that on
the mattress that he must sleep in.
And this is one of those
great pension, uh, sentences.
This is a question,
but it comes in the declarative form
to what voices over heard Flinders of
luminescent God's glimpse to among
the wallpapers. Stained foliage,
candle stubs lit to rotate
in the air over him.
Prefiguring the cigarette he or a friend
must fall asleep someday. Smoking.
Thus to end among the flaming secrets
salts held all those years by the
insatiable stuffing of a mattress that
could keep vestiges of every nightmare.
Sweat,
helpless over flowing bladder viciously.
Tearfully Kunz consummated wet dream
like the memory bank to a computer of the
lost. It's assertive. Um,
Aria of description and pension can
string those clauses together like no one
else. Uh, there are even longer examples
in the book and I'm sure you notice them
at our pod needs to
actually touch the man.
And when she finally sort
of takes him in her arms,
the position she assumes looks like that
of a mother with her broken sun and the
image is much more specifically
of Michelangelo's Pieta.
And remember the Lago DPA tough figures
prominently in the novel both as the
site of the,
um,
the route of Gis in Italy and the lake,
uh,
from which their bones are taken to
make charcoal filters for cigarettes.
So the PA ta the image of Mary with Jesus'
body broken from the cross on her lap
is repeated and here at a puck
comes to inhabit that position.
It's not a social role in the
that she could be granddaughter,
Lee or motherly.
On those other occasions,
it's a religious image.
It's also a,
a gendered religious image.
It's also an aesthetic image.
But here it's infused with her
compassionate approach to this man.
And remember in the passage that
I read about in varieties, estate,
what she sort of left with
as her final understanding.
She has a kind of compassion for peers
and the way that he had surrounded
himself with this network of holdings
that he had tried to escape from in some
way.
So if you cannot finally
have a pattern resolve into a
clarity of truth or meaning,
what you can do instead is in habit a
role where you will be in contact with the
very material of social life.
And that's what that mattress is totally
imbued with the bodily detritus of a
human life actually have many human lives.
She reflects later on the set of all
men who had slept on that mattress.
Okay?
Pension wants to imagine a very
physical repository for the social
and especially for the human
aspect of dimensions of the social.
That's why Adam [inaudible] has all
these men stripped away from her.
Remember she says it as she's growing
more and more desperate at the end that
her men were being stripped
away from her one by one.
And so when she comes to
be isolated in this way,
she can finally see and
meditate upon in a new way.
All those systems of communication.
And she has that vision of the telephone
wires and she looks up at them as she's
just doubted all the possibilities for
making sense of the post torn in the true
Stero. She looks up at the telephone wires
and she thinks about all the messages
unintelligible full of human longing
going back and forth across those wires.
So if pension gives us,
uh,
the pattern of meaning rather
than meaning itself in this novel,
he also gives us a vision of what
it means to embody that pattern.
This is very different from Nabar coughs,
idea of embodiment as a kind of
alternate or rival creativity.
Remember,
I argued that Lolita has a dead child
and she dies in childbirth in a way
because it's a kind of creativity that
novakof wants to cancel or that Humbert
wants to cancel.
Okay.
In this novel, it's not
arrival. Creativity,
it's what creativity has to
be in the literary sense.
Now pension was a student of Nobach
offs for a couple of years at Cornell
university in the early sixties so he
took, he took courses with Nabokov.
I don't know how close they were.
Um,
but he certainly learned a
few things from to back off.
This is something he revises
from that old teacher.
He is imagining a literary form that
is soaked in the stuff of social life.
So if you only get a sniff of
the tear gas in Barth here,
you get a whole draft full of it.
And what I think he is rejecting,
if you look on page 95
oops,
that's not the one I want.
Okay.
Yes,
it is 95 if you look on page 95 here's
a different vision of what the artwork
could look like that I think we're meant
to put next to that vision of at a Po
with the suffering sailor.
Yeah.
This is when it first occurs to her
that the whole world is being organized
around her.
Nothing of the nights could touch her.
Nothing did.
The repetition of symbols was to
be enough without trauma as well,
perhaps to attenuate it or even jar
it altogether loose from her memory.
She was meant to remember.
She faced that possibility as she might
the toy street from a high balcony
roller coaster ride feeding time
among the beasts at the zoo in a zoo.
Any death wish that can be
consummated by some minimum gesture.
She touched the edge of its voluptuous
field knowing it would be lovely beyond
dreams simply to submit to it that not
gravity's pull laws of ballistics feral
ravening promised more delight.
She tested it. Shivering.
I meant to remember each clue that comes
is supposed to have its own clarity.
It's fine chances for permanence,
but then she wondered if the gem like
clues were only some kind of compensation
to make up for her.
Having lost the direct epileptic word,
the cry that might abolish the night.
Yeah.
This is a meditation on both the joy and
the loss of literary substitution for
the real or for the truth,
the substitution of abstract pattern for
something like comprehensible meaning.
So here she's kind of enthralled with
the idea that these gem like clues,
that's a very new Nabokovian moment.
The gem like clues that are gathering
around her would be a compensation for the
loss of that real access to revelation.
And this has this religious sense to it.
It's not just the religious instant
of looking down at San Narcisso,
it's the religious sense
of the capitalized word
that comes back a couple of
times towards the end of the novel,
the epileptic word,
the word capitalized always refers back
to the beginning of the gospel of John,
where John Describes Christ
as the word made flesh.
The word was with God
and the word was God.
And the word was made flesh
and came to dwell among us.
So pension is using that
religious vocabulary,
not just the religious
imagery of the PA ta,
but the religious vocabulary
of the capitalized word.
So you can have a kind of
system of symbols that's
gem like and pleasurable and
that calls you to submit to
it as it does here for at OPA.
But in the end there is something
more that her search will produce.
And that is the moment of compassion.
And I would submit to you that,
um, tears are just all over this novel.
I don't know if you noticed it, but,
um, there are many, many examples.
I'll just give you a few. Um,
first of all,
there the tears that accumulate in
her bubble shades when she's in Mexico
looking at the Remedios Varo painting of
the women in the tower embroidering the
long tapestries that become the world.
So that sense of isolation in the
tower makes her weep on one 17.
Can see another example.
Yeah.
Um, this is, uh, mucho
talking about the Muzak, um,
at up of the human voice. You
know, it's a flipping miracle.
His eyes brimming reflecting
the color of beer.
One 13.
Yeah,
this is doctor hilarious crying.
Tears Sprang to hilarious. His eyes,
you aren't going to shoot. He says, um,
one 46 in her moment of desperation
when she loses her connection to the MRI
motto and anonymous,
um,
or when she's about to talk to him,
she waited in explicable,
tears beginning to build up
pressure around her eyes.
Um, back on one. Oh,
this is the nurse, uh, who has just
escaped from doctor. Hilarious.
He thinks someone's after him.
Tear streaks had meandered down
over the nurses cheekbones.
It's not just that we could explain
any of these moments of tears.
It's that pension describes them,
all notes them all.
So this is a novel that's
full of people crying,
which is an odd thing to think about when
you think back to pensions reputation
as a metaphor actional novelist,
as someone preeminently preoccupied
with the formal aspects of fiction,
what you find when you actually open up
pensions novels is an incredibly rich
world of human detritus of
history in gravity's rainbow.
He did enormous amounts of
research in newspapers, um,
from the Second World War in London where
some of this is some of the novel is
set so that you can go to newspapers and
find the ads that he talks about in the
novels.
So he combines this very
attentive set of details,
which are not always and often are not
at all the aesthetic details with which
Novaka filled Lolita.
I remember when I asked you about the
specificity of America and on the road and
asked you to think about whether there
was anything there at all in on the road.
There isn't anything
in the back off there is,
but it's usually aesthetic how
things look. The look of a hotel,
the look of a field, the look of a
child, the look of a woman in pension.
Often these are somehow social details
about people talking to other people,
political things,
um,
places and how houses are arranged.
But there is a sense that
these are social worlds,
not just patterns,
even though at the beginning that's how
adipose sees them as she goes further
and further into her search for knowledge.
And finally her abandonment of
that search of knowledge. Um,
she sees more and more that
this is not just pattern,
that it's these storm systems
of suffering and need.
So I think this is what pension brings
to the string of meditations on what
language can do and what
the novel is for that.
I began my lecture today
with just recapping for you.
He's trying to imagine a novel that
meditates both on these structures of
meaning that imbue the real world,
such that there's no name that isn't
already saturated with associations
and that within such a world,
if you enter into it,
you can come to encounter the real and
the real is that sense of suffering and
that the novel can make you feel things,
both
the pleasure of humor or
the pleasure of beauty,
but also that sense of compassion.
And I don't know about you,
but I feel compassion for at OPA.
I feel like she's a real character.
I think she is a character that you can
if not identify with at least you can
understand and be interested in.
So pension offers us that and in our
next reading when we start with Toni
Morrison and also in Maxine Hong Kingston,
what you're going to
see is a kind of shift.
So all these meditations on language,
these different ways of thinking about
how language interacts with the real and
what you can do by messing with
language are almost, I would say,
taken as read,
taken as the starting point from which
a writer like Morrison or Kingston will
begin to rethink how those things can
be used in relation to the real world.
So that's where we'll start when we
think about Morrison next week. Um,
let me just also say there are a thousand
things to talk about in this novel.
So I hope you'll get to
some of them in section.
And if you want to write about this,
it's a very rich novel
for writing your papers.